was there anything else that popped up
while you were pulling up this uh data
on dr kim
um or any other lessons maybe that guy
should pay attention to when it comes to
stuff
i mean like i sometimes see these
stories and i think to myself yeah like
you didn't know like you didn't have
a clue before you you know you invited
her into your world and decided to marry
her
the like is that is that something that
you see happen a lot in your practice
like are guys deceived that often
yeah they get deceived once in a while
um
and it's there are it's already too late
they're one or two children in
it could be a few years in and
what i see a lot which i don't know how
you could vet for this
but i see guys get married
to their hearts desire and then their
heart's desire
says i got him i got him i don't have to
take care of myself
uh i could do whatever i want uh i could
be disrespectful
i mean that's really painful to see but
it happens a lot
and we'll tell you how you can vet for
that i mean like watch how she behaves
to other people
that aren't you i mean if you're dealing
with the actor if you're dealing with
the representative when you're going out
to dinner she's rude to the wait staff
or you know the busboy the uh you know
the co clerk you know for example the
guy that parks your car you know the
ballet
if she's rude to those guys but she's
pleasant to you
guess what buddy because you're because
you're going to be next at some point
too totally she's going to pull that
exact same move on you at some point in
the very near future probably after
you know the nuptials and the ideas and
all that sort of stuff
right right exactly um you know
i just in my notes as i was reading
about this case
you know you got to vet very carefully
and we say that every time but
even if you're the most careful vetter
people can change
and some can wear that mask just long
enough to get married
and then you're finished um you got to
stay firm to your truth so i see a lot
of guys who
they get married against their better
judgment you know
i thought she was like the best i could
do and i
didn't have that much experience and my
family was pushing me
and you know i like that warm body at
night
and yikes that's a recipe for disaster
uh but it happens a lot how long did the
date
date before they got married did it say
anywhere well if he was
in a picture with her in 2011 i have
been assuming
at least four years so four years so he
met her at the miss connecticut that she
won
or around that time married her in 2015
so
i mean he gave it a good few years i
mean i've always said you want to give
it at least a couple years to see what
she's made of right you know see
see what happens when bad stuff happens
in a relationship how you know how she
handles stress
stuff like that right or if she doesn't
get her way
or are you giving her no i'm not doing
that no
to a woman and watch how she responds
you're going to learn a lot about them
when you do that right
now if you're on your purpose and you're
running a business or you like to
fish or hunt or play hockey whatever you
brings you joy
and that's getting on her in her way no
don't do it i don't care who it is uh
you're going to end up in my office when
we don't want you here you know we want
you to be happy um
but you know the title of tonight's talk
was uh
divorcing problem women so i have like a
short list of things
that you might really want to uh have
your guys think about
uh number one thing if you find yourself
in a bad situ
now if you're not married it doesn't
matter you could just walk uh but
there's exceptions to that too that i'll
talk about in a minute but
keep your emotions in check never get
emotional
some of these folks are crazy on the
other side
uh you don't know if they're a sociopath
a psychopath
narcissistic so keep your emotions in
check it will just
feed and perpetuate a bad divorce if you
react
to anything she says or does all right
so
gray rock is my watchword to the guys
just gray rock it man pass it over to me
you get a nasty text
she says something to you nesty outside
the courtroom
let it go all right anything that's uh
really
relevant pass it along to me but don't
start fighting
always focus on the end game if you're
going through a bad divorce you know you
want to get out of this
with your skin all right you made a
mistake somebody
wants to take your head off for no fault
of yours
focus on the end game and uh that's
usually a good recipe
uh to get everybody focused and my side
it's calm gray rock don't fight about it
um you got to come to the grip
come to grips with the fact that you
gave it your best shot you know don't
don't beat yourself up all right more
than half of the
first marriages end in divorce anyway
you're not the first you're not going to
be the last
if there's no kids involved thank
goodness for that because that's a whole
nother issue
a whole set of issues actually so you
want to uh
just gray rock come to grips go get
mental health help it's no shame in it
uh get get uh counseling
and let's see
here's a couple practical tips if you're
going through a nasty divorce too that i
tell all my guys
uh stay off the social media all right
especially
if you're dating a starlet or you know
some beautiful woman no way
are you on any social media why you're
going to stir the pot
all right we don't want to stir the pot
we want to get out of this
uh with your skin all right and more if
we can
so don't give her any excuses to deny a
proper settlement or a good offer
all right and that beautiful babe that
you've been dating
uh keep her off of social media
and to that don't even introduce them to
your kids
uh let's get through this without them
going to mom's house
and saying wow you know daddy's new
girlfriend looks like uh
miss america all right it happens
and how some of these guys are you know
they're finally free
from a couple years or more of a sexless
marriage
and um they have what it you know
they're
they're terrific guys who are in shape
and
fit got their money right got a target
on their back which is another thing i
talked to them about
and of course i'm telling everybody
who's looking for a lawyer
search vigorously and select wisely you
know there's no rush
if nobody's been served yet uh you know
make sure you have somebody that you can
work with
and it's got your best interest and is
gonna do what needs to get done
and once you choose somebody listen to
them listen
okay because if you don't why are you
paying them why'd you hire them there's
enough lawyers out there
pick somebody that you like and that
you're gonna listen to um
this is kind of uh for lack of a better
word
crash but it's it's true
like it or not the way the laws are set
up in most jurisdictions
unless you want to be in a situation
that could bring a world to hurt
you if you want to get married you
should try to marry someone who's at
your economic level or higher
uh it's just the way the laws are
written uh
you if you are making a lot of money
let's say
mid six figures and she's never made
more than 40 or 50 000
a year she doesn't have the earning
capacity
like let's say uh so you're going to be
on the short
end all along the way all right whether
it's child support
or uh your spousal support
or in some jurisdictions alimony
pendente lite
in some jurisdictions uh alimony i mean
so the economics are always a factor
unless you're one of the few fortunate
ones who have an amicable
parting of the ways where she says one
great illustration of this recently too
because when dr dre
um settled with his wife i think he's
paying three hundred thousand dollars a
month to her
nobody really said too much aside from
that sucks um but when kelly clarkson
about a week later uh settled and she's
paying
her ex-husband who was making less money
than she was so what jonathan's talking
about you know don't marry down
um she's paying something like 200 250
a month it's quite a bad it's it's it's
slightly less than dre but it's
it's still several several hundred
thousand dollars everybody lost their
ever-loving mind
oh and what ground should a grown-ass
man have to rely on
you know like his wife to or his ex-wife
to pay for his lifestyle and blah blah
blah
it's it's but it's i mean i'd love to
say it's bizarre but it doesn't surprise
me that
you know nobody says anything when dre's
got to pay big bucks but kelly clarkson
everybody loses their mind because he
should be able to stand on his own two
feet
yeah i mean the dre situation
is a two-hour discussion because it's so
interesting at least to me and
california laws
are what they are just like ontario laws
are they're nothing like many of the
other jurisdictions that i'm familiar
with
based on what i've read about ontario uh
british columbia trumps ontario frankly
and
we could talk about that for a minute
but uh one other thing that i wanted to
point out when you're talking about
problem women
and vetting you really got to know their
past now i'm a baby boomer so
i date women or dated women who have
been married like two or three times and
the story is always the same
oh he was this he was that or he was
abusive or is lazy like
it's never their fault it's like always
like
i have a video coming out soon on that
topic so
obviously my eyes are wide open and my
ears are wide open and i just
listen and process and say holy smokes
she's the common denominator in every
single one of those matrimonial
equations and if she's always pointing
and sputtering at him
he cheated he was abusive he was
financially abusive blah blah blah like
one of the questions you can ask women
when when they start you know lecturing
you on
how bad all men are that have been in
her life
so what did you do wrong in those
relationships right right like
see if they're willing to take some
ownership another tip-off
for me at least uh was when i heard i
only got
xyz in my first divorce or
he he really got away with so much and i
know there were accounts in the grand
cayman islands and
he had a lawyer who was a bulldog and so
whenever
i would hear something like that i'd be
like
go be somebody else's problem this is
crazy
uh so i'm mentioning this kind of thing
because maybe there's guys out there who
haven't heard this or they don't have
anyone to tell him you know trust your
gut and listen
and this is not made-up stuff you know
it happens all the time
and you want to try to never be in a
position where
you are in a bad divorce or you're
trying to divorce a difficult person
i've seen the most vindictive people in
my divorce practice
and at the end of the day you know they
end up spending everybody's money
when they could send their kids to
europe or or
wherever you know it's just crazy but
don't
goes back to the emotions don't let it
get the best of you
you